great show tonight
great chill tonight tomorrow night from
the new movie a Fast Food Nation and the
Broadway play a coast of utopia
Ethan Hawke is gonna be joining me
comedian Jim Gaffigan will be here with
a new episode of pale force and a
musical guest the brand New Heavies so
check that show out that could be good
[Applause]
it's in HD Alyson Hannigan gonna be out
here in just a second but first there's
a character that loves to stop by our
show from time to time people always are
happy to see this gentleman let me tell
you about him he simply travels the
world handing out preparation-h to
anyone that wants it please welcome
preparation-h Raymond
biking if your rump is irritated Raven
tear Raymond tear rub that where your
irrigated Raven to you to help if you
suffer from sinker pain
Raymond tear Raymond tear squirt a
little miss around the drain by the
handout some freebies to your incredible
crowd you know just see what many of you
call Thanksgiving weekend I more
accurately referred to as five nights of
rectal hell 5 nights of rectal hell oh
yes and it begins tonight after we all
spent eight hours in a holiday traffic
jam we all then sit an additional hour
on our asses watching this show okay and
this causes the colon to get tender and
swollen and puffy
I didn't start saying oh you don't
forget about me you're real sensitive
say your colon talks yes I think what we
do the next day that's turkey day and we
say I know what'll make my bugger feel
better
so that's night two of the five nights
of rectal hell yeah and then the other
three nights are all spent playing
scattegories with a bunch of relatives
you didn't even know you had
and by the end your cheeks are so shaped
that the only way you can walk around is
by pretending you got can't believe that
got a round of applause well I'm not
quite sure things will go that way but
Raymond we do appreciate your warning oh
well you're very welcoming folks if you
don't want rectal he'll avoid the rectal
swell guarantee holiday fun by squeezing
the tube between your bum that's for you
sugar if you wolf down stuffing and you
don't feel slim Raymond's here Ravens
here cake this goop around the chair to
help
we'll take a break come back
alyson hannigan here
[Applause]